les vélos sont de sortie malgré le
risque d'averse noémie et son mari sont
bien décidés à faire leur balade autour
de briare on est confiant on a regardé
la météo ça devrait être stable nous
avons deux parapluies les ponchos enfin
on est tous 16 et 33 km le vélo fait son
festival autour de deux parcours qui ont
surtout attiré les inconditionnels de la
petite reine
nous on aime bien une petite randonnée
courte de la journée le tronçon loire à
vélo là il était magnifique
vraiment ça vaut sur la route cyclo
touristique
il a des étapes très appréciables comme
celle de la fête des vins de bonny sur
loire incontournable on pouvait pas la
louper
on a n'a pas pu être là l'année dernière
donc je cette année c'était obligé
d'être présent avec quand on essaie de
joindre l'utile à l'agréable et puis 2
déc l occasion de faire des trucs un peu
plus loufoques le faire à briare de
retour de leur balade
les cyclistes ont pu croiser la
globe-trotteuse philomène le lait elle a
réalisé à vélo le tour de l'amérique du
sud de l'océanie je crois vraiment ce
qui me plaît le plus là dedans et
j'aurais jamais cru faire tout ça c'est
que on rencontre des gens il ya des
choses qui se passent à l'instant t il
ya les galères qui se passe à l'instant
t mais qui font des beaux souvenirs et
voilà c'est la simplicité rencontrer des
gens et voir des choses qu'on n'a pas
fait un listing de tous qu'on doit aller
voir aller faire je ne savais jamais où
j'allais dormir le soir même
c'est ce qui me plaît le plus c'est ce
que j'ai envie de transmettre allez pour
finir un petit tour sur un granby pour
se rappeler aussi l'âge vénérable de la
bicyclette